KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
Joining me in this
studio is Max.
He is a former Googler, multiple
time Founder, and currently
working on AltSchool.
Max, thanks for joining us.
MAX VENTILLA: Thanks
for having me.
I'm actually a
former Googler twice.
KORY JEFFREY: Twice.
MAX VENTILLA: And then I came
back and then I left again.
KORY JEFFREY: So let's
start with that story then.
MAX VENTILLA: So I had done a
startup in college basically
and just kind of got my
ass handed to me, and said,
OK, there's a lot of
things that I need
to know before I do that again.
And so one of them
was I wanted to work
for a really great,
awesome company that
modeled for me the kind of
company I wanted to build.
And so after working for an
amazing company in Europe
and finishing my
MBA, I went to Google
and was part of this kind of
small corporate strategy group
and got that crazy itch to
start something, not least
because an amazing person
was finishing a PhD
and I wanted to start a
company with him forever.
And so I did that.
And then Google ended up
buying the start-up, Aardvark,
like two and a half years later.
And so I ended up
back at Google.
KORY JEFFREY: And now
left Google again--
MAX VENTILLA: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: --to do AltSchool.
MAX VENTILLA: That's right.
KORY JEFFREY: So
tell us about that.
MAX VENTILLA: So it's been
about two and a half years.
So I was running the
personalization team
prior to leaving Google, and got
to work on things like Google
Now, and just really
felt like there
was a role for personalization
to play in the broader world
and education specifically.
And I'm a parent.
I had a two-year-old
daughter at the time
and was very much thinking
about school and future school.
And just when you have
that Google experience,
you are trained to
think about the world
in a certain way,
which is around scale
and continuous improvement.
And that's at odds with what
I saw in the education space
where schools are structurally
resistant to change.
There aren't the
kind of resources
to really do a kind
of R&D enablement
of some transformative
new model.
And so that kind of
possessed me and a number
of other folks from Google
and an amazing child
center and educators
that we partnered with.
We've been working on
that journey of how
do you really transform the
ecosystem in which people start
and run schools, starting
with a set of schools
that we operate ourselves that
have a level of technology
enablement that's unheard of.
So we have 150 people
working for AltSchool.
50 of them are
educators and 50 of them
are engineers, many of them
from places like Google.
And that kind of
one-to-one ratio
is something you don't see.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah,
yeah, for sure.
And so I noticed when
I was reading about it
that it said you are able to
get a level of personalization
without resulting
to screen learning.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
MAX VENTILLA: Sure.
So I thing that the most
important technologies
for a classroom should be
invisible from the classroom
for the most part
in the same way
that the most important
technologies from driving
aren't so obvious when you
get behind the wheel of a car.
There are things that go
into the safety, and the GPS,
and the testing, and
eventually to things
like the car's steering
itself with Tesla and ones
that will follow.
And so similarly,
we want to think
about how do we set up that
classroom to be most dynamic,
to be most responsive to what
each child in that classroom
needs in terms of what classroom
they're in to begin with,
with what educators
and what peers,
and what kind of
curriculum they're pursuing
and extracurriculars, and
then down to having each child
be able to be on a different
trajectory each week
with 20 to 25 different
activities in their playlist
that all can be assessed
in almost real time, where
those playlist items should be
happening primarily offline.
But there should be a
digital representation.
There should be an
interoperability
between classrooms.
And there should be a level
of transparency and rigor
that's very hard to
accomplish in a scaled way
without relying on technologies,
in this case, technologies
you need to build yourself
from the ground up.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
So you said you were
running schools.
How many children have
you educated so far?
MAX VENTILLA: How many
children have we educated?
We have 330 students
in our schools today.
We've only been around
for two and a half years.
So we started with lower
and upper elementary,
that first pilot year with
just a one-room schoolhouse.
And then we expanded to include
middle school the next year.
And we literally only had
one kid graduate that year.
We intended to have none and
give ourselves a little more
time to graduate a student.
But this guy Zev came along
and was just too awesome.
We said, OK.
We're going to admit you.
And it was a good call.
So we'll have more and more
kids in the years that follow.
KORY JEFFREY: And so this
sounds like right now you're
working off of your own
kind of high-touch model.
Like you said, you have
to have only an ecosystem
with engineering
and the educators.
How do you see this kind of
rolling out to a public school
system in the future?
Or do you?
MAX VENTILLA: Yeah.
So we think of it in kind
of a three-phased approach,
where phase one is we're
the only inhabitants
of this transformatively
different ecosystem that
doesn't start out
that transformatively,
but we build, and we
iterate, and we invest.
And we start chasing
that kind of hockey
stick curve that has
a long flat part.
And we're the only
client of that ecosystem.
It's only our schools that
exist in this kind of AltSchool
world.
But over time,
and we think we're
maybe halfway in that
five-year journey
to where we can start to invite
other people in that ecosystem.
And you'll see charter
schools, public schools,
Montessori schools,
international baccalaureate
schools start in
this new universe
that makes it much easier
to operate a great school.
Today it's way too hard to
start and run a bad school,
let alone a good school.
And you look at something
like Montessori,
which is the best out-of-the-box
approach we have for lower
elementary, it's over 100 years.
There's no technology
enabled in it.
There's no significant
network effect.
And we want to create this
ecosystem, which in phase two
allows more and more people
to start more and more diverse
schools that still meet that
high bar of what a school
today should be in terms of
being personalized, in terms
of being iterative, in
terms of being data-driven.
in terms of using
technology in the right way,
not to replace
relationship-driven real-world
learning but to kind
of superpower it.
And eventually over the long
term, we hope to kind of move
to the third phase,
where we represent
a viable option for
existing schools and school
systems which will educate
the majority of kids
for the foreseeable future to
do things in a different way,
in a different place in the
same way as after 20 years,
from '95 to 2015, this
internet ecosystem
now represents the way that
even the most traditional media
players and content providers
increasingly operate.
And we want a similar
dynamic to take place
over the next decades.
KORY JEFFREY: That's very cool.
It's like a long-tailed
infiltration of the education
system.
That's cool.
So you're at Founder World.
There's like thousands of really
interesting tech, entrepreneur,
non-tech people here.
What attracted
you to this event?
MAX VENTILLA: So I like
any opportunity to go
spout off to people that
haven't rammed their head
into the same walls as I have.
I don't think it's
worth that much.
At the end of the day,
you learn by doing,
and you learn by being
alongside someone doing.
And someone telling you
can't really make big impact.
But I wouldn't have
started AltSchool
if I wouldn't have
heard Elon Musk talk
in a few individual situations.
So maybe I can be the
poor man's Elon Musk
and talk to people that are
even earlier in their career.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
MAX VENTILLA: So I like that.
It's something I think is built
into the startup ethos, which
is you pay it forward.
So like when there is
a great audience, when
it's very much about how
do you inspire, how do you
give actual tactical advice
as well to the next generation
of entrepreneurs, I want to do a
certain number of those a year.
And we like the people
organizing this event,
so I was happy to do it.
KORY JEFFREY: And so you
were on stage, obviously,
earlier talking to potential
young entrepreneurs
early in their career.
What was the message
you were getting across?
MAX VENTILLA: So
for me, the message
is mostly about you want
to focus on the long term.
Startups tend to fail.
They take a lot of time.
They take a lot of money.
And you want to set yourself up
assuming that those things are
true, which means not relying
on intelligent design,
like a hunch you have,
and then you go, go, go
as fast as you possibly can.
It's to kind of use
first principles,
assume you're wrong,
iterate, iterate, iterate,
focus on acceleration, put
the earliest version out there
that you can and start
learning as soon as possible,
be quantitatively and
qualitatively user driven.
And in the earliest phases, try
to weed out false positives,
and don't worry about
false negatives.
Who cares if you didn't
do the thing that
would have been the next
billion dollar startup.
All you care about is
not doing the thing
that ends up being a failure.
KORY JEFFREY: That's
cool, actually,
So as you walk
around here, there's
all sorts of different
booths, all sorts
of different technologies.
Is there anything particular
here or otherwise in the tech
space today that gets
you really excited?
MAX VENTILLA: Yeah.
So I haven't had the
chance to walk around here.
I think that there are some
amazing building blocks that
have been put into place.
So obviously, things like cloud
infrastructure and big data
analytics are extremely
interesting to me.
I think that they are
moving into things
that allow consumer behavior.
So the proliferation
of mobile payments,
super interesting to me.
More seamless identity, the fact
that I can use my thumbprint
and put in my Amazon
password on a mobile site,
I think that stuff is going to
grease the wheels for actually
a transformatively different
way that we behave online.
I'm now interested in
more lately things that
allow us to in the real
world make fast progress
around digital systems.
So that could be anything from--
like Texas Instruments makes
a kind of wearable chip
that's very easy to play with.
Intel is starting to do some
really interesting things
with transistors for mobile.
So I think that just
lowering the bar for people
to get started on
real world devices
is especially interesting for
me in a real world venture that
still wants to use technology.
And there's some critical
kind of AIP pieces
that come along with
that in terms of things
like voice transcription.
It's amazing to me that I can
open up Siri or Google Now,
and it could basically,
in this noisy room,
do a pretty good
job transcribing.
I want to be able to
use that kind of stuff.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
And so being a two-time
Googler and obviously
a tech entrepreneur, what
is your favorite Google
technology?
MAX VENTILLA: I mean, Google
Search is just transformative.
I think Google Search on
mobile is just amazing,
being able to give it to my
daughter who expects that.
Anything she wants to know--
KORY JEFFREY: Is there.
MAX VENTILLA: At any time.
I just think she's
going to become
a different human being as a
result. It's so cool to watch.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
Well, thank you,
Max, for joining us.
It was great to have you here.
And thank you, guys,
for joining us.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Fransisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]